Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Chris?
No. No. Okay. No.
Wow.
Yes.
Seven. Wow. Yes.
Come on.
Yep.
Hello?
No.
Wow.
Yeah.
Maybe half man.
His Mama.
Wow.
Yep.
Nope. My mouth.
You guys mind?
I told the Jeff kind of the all
time great drops from the show
cause my pussy ladies this was this the
original wells Fargo commercial from
Wells Fargo? Yeah, she was there.
She saw original spokeswoman share the
half a million and they didn't give it to
her and
the Bank of America and you
Chinese mother fuckers, um,
Joe Murphy made this. It's
really good. Thanks Joe. My
mom would get mad and she would say
things like that to not kiss my butt.
She would say it gives my
buzzy was the kind of thing,
if you're the person that
you're like, um, yeah.
Your mom probably didn't know how that
came across everybody in the room, right?
No, yeah, no. It was just part of
the fun and being with her. Yeah.
It's part of the fun of having a cool mom.
Cool.
Having a eccentric, her
mom. Just kind of weird.
Can I hear myself more? You can.
I think you were this one right?
It's good. Yeah. I like your
voice. It's very masculine.
Thank you. I've been told that. I've been
told, yeah, you've a real man's voice.
Solar fans met a fan this morning.
You did in the hotel. We, we celebrated
our Banis Murphy Ernie last night.
These best wherever any of,
not just being married but also a
raw dog in it does. Right. And uh,
we're hoping to get more raw dog.
We got some raw dog tweets. We did.
I didn't get any, you must
have just gotten really
telling me the raw dog stuff.
Yeah. Yeah. Go guys. Generally don't
tweet me about their raw dog. Joy's,
that's just for you.
But we,
we went back to the same hotel that
we ride dogged in. That's right. A,
how many years ago was that? 12
years ago? Yes. Around yesterday.
And we got a couple's massage,
which you're not a fan of.
So I was really surprised
that you, I booked it. Right.
But remember last time I asked you a while
back, do you want a couple's massage?
And you went what?
No, no I didn't ask you. The woman did
that worked at the SPA. She goes do you,
would you like a couple's massage and
your level of disdain for the very id.
And I tell you something though,
I tell you something about that was a
huge upcharge yesterday and really it was
really just to have two
and two in the same room.
But I mean like I think it's because
the illusion of that being a thing like
the,
the marketing of it is something
that's not compatible with the reality.
Like we just in the same room. Yeah,
nothing happens, nothing special.
I can hear your lady going like,
is that comfortable?
And you can hear my lady going is
that temperature right on the bay?
There was nothing happening now.
So how did you feel about it?
Cause I didn't ask you,
did you like the couples experience?
Would you do it again or you just seem
like it seemed like the only thing that
stood out about it was that I'm
hearing a conversation going on.
Yeah, that's it. That's it.
I mean literally we walked
in the room, they leave.
We both get our tables and then I get
to hear your ladies and then this is his
pressure is good. And
then do you want, uh,
as you want the music louder and then
when I heard that you don't like loud
music, you asked her to turn it down.
Now I prefer lab and use it. Yeah.
I like to space out.
I like to get weird,
which is another argument for separate
room. I agree. Well that's when we,
when we went into the massage spa and
she goes to for a couple's massage,
I literally looked at
her, I went, fuck you. No,
I booked it and you book it that way.
And then she goes, wait, I'm confused.
And I go, all right, I guess we're doing
it. Yeah. Well I felt like, you know,
it's our band, a SMURF,
Fernie, you do that to try it.
But I'm saying in retrospect to
pay more for that, it's foolish.
It seems silly to me. Foolish.
They didn't do anything special.
Like there's those champagne in the
room. Nobody masturbated. No Bra,
strawberries, you to come.
A lot of people by the way,
on board with the Shark Shark Bites,
um, analysis and they're like, yeah,
movies stupid. There's no
masturbation saying, by the way,
to everybody that always talks about um,
pre show.
There's commercials. This is pre
show right now, right? Yeah. We're,
we're doing pre show and you're already
your borough. You're breaking my balls.
You're breaking my balls right now.
Pre show there's content and you're
saying there's no content and you're lying
and you're mom's a liar too. Yeah. So
fill her up.
Delphia has been a promoted date of mine
for a long time and it's finally here.
I'm really excited to go jeans.
I've never been to Philadelphia.
I've been to the tits bird.
I'm doing four shows at the cockpit,
Dera theater and fill her up.
Um,
I'm real excited about it. I want to
thank everybody. So we got tickets.
It should be for pact.
Really Fun.
Shows the Great Josh Potter is joining me.
She'd be a good time Josh.
Yeah, he's great. He's great. Um,
after that we have thanksgiving.
We'll bill you.
We'll do an anti Thanksgiving thanksgiving
week. Then I go to west balls,
beach, Florida, the Improv, um,
four shows only in west palm.
Please come out if you dare.
Uh,
we're going to have a lot of fun there.
I'm home a lot in December,
but I do get new year's
eve in mom, Lando, Florida,
the Improv there.
That should be fun.
And then I start a crazy tour throughout
the first quarter of 2017 and in
January I had Kansas City,
Oxnard,
newer genes, new horror jeans. Um,
Atlanta,
clear brown water,
Florida and ticket Talla Hussey,
Florida as well.
It's my first weekend of the big tour.
I'm doing really excited about it. Jeans.
I know you're going to Washington. Dick,
come to welcome our new president
and that's going to be in December.
That's right.
President Camacho.
He's going to be racing dirt bikes on
the line and I'm going to go watch that
happen. Yeah. December 9th and 10th,
2017 Tva guys still working on it.
Just had the call at the agents today.
So let's see. So, um, that'll
be a fun week for you.
That club is so great. We're
doing two nights. Yeah.
Two nights only,
which is great. In and out. Get
your, get your tickets, tickets,
ted, Ted's, um, thousand ranch.com.
Tom segora.com and your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Don't forget the holidays
are getting closer. Uh,
also thanked too for two cool ed for
the, you know, instrumental here.
Holidays are getting closer,
which means don't forget to your
Amazon shopping shop for your Christmas
presents. Sorry. Your mom is on. Go
to your mom's house, podcast.com.
Click on the moment is on banner
and do your shopping there.
Have it gift wrapped and have it shipped.
Dude,
don't get on a plane with
gifts and cray cray Kwanzaa.
Christ mass
Chaunika forgotten. Nobody
celebrates cons on America. I don't,
I've never,
never known one person.
I've known a couple of brothers
here and the other do it. Oh yeah.
Couple a fist in the air guys. Yeah. That
white rapper from last week, Jay love.
You know what I'm saying? Cornball
mode. Fuck his nose. He was ridiculous.
So retired colon bowl.
That's a, is that a new word?
A cornball I'd been a not a lot.
I mean it's not a new movie.
It's saying maybe there's
a resurgence of it,
but I feel like coming back
we'll focus McCone man,
I feel like that's,
he looked just like him when you said it.
If I had trimmed his beard the way
mind, the way his is, I could probably,
I could be Jay love for, uh,
for, for hollow jeans next year.
I really wish you shave it. I it looks
good. I know, man. It looks so real. Talk.
Don't get on an airplane with packages.
You know you're going to travel for
Christmas and all that sauce. Stupid.
Don't do it.
Cause that TSA,
they're going to go through it and they're
going to unwrap everything and you're
really going to regret it. Just have
it sent directly to where you're going.
Have it sends an advance then you
don't have to pack a Goddamn thing.
And the other thing is don't you even
consider not checking out our store?
We have a new store. There's
a lot of stuff on there. Um,
well mainly the, the one
stuff that matters is the
water. A lot of championship,
which I in the water champ,
this is my flask. I found it.
You'd be hit it last week.
Water champion shirt, um,
is a hot seller. It's a great
Christmas gift. Christmas,
especially if my friends or dating or
married to someone who's at your mom's
house fan.
So also the Dj Dad mouth thing,
which I have a hilarious comment
from one of the youtube videos.
Okay. Let's get into it.
Okay. I was going to say,
you were saying that if you are in a
couple of yourself listening and you guys
are debating who's the water champ,
it's a great shirt to get to prove
that you really are. Yeah, absolutely.
Is that my favorite Dan Pena?
Yup. We got all kinds of things.
I was so excited for this interview. I
was sweating out of anticipation. Yeah.
I don't care. I mean, like I said,
we've interviewed major celebrities like
brace from Juggalos. Yeah. Uh, Gloria.
Stefan has been on the show jewels Venter,
Aka Jules drools.
And by far Dan Pena has been the most
super exciting, amazing interview.
I'm just so thrilled.
Let's start the show. No.
Well, why aren't my favorite sayings
is that got your fucking patty goes,
you're trying.
Yeah. Did you start to use current
more as you when you moved to the UK?
Because I love it. Oh No, no, no, no.
Transition from cock vagina.
I'm standing soaking enough now.
Don't bring in one love to this. Well, no,
no.
Go to your mom's house,
Christina visits.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah. Concen vaginas. So many
guns. He switched to vagina.
He said cause con wasn't crazy enough.
Yeah. Oh No, you turned my ears down.
That's when your ears down.
Yeah. Out. Okay. Yeah.
What a treat. What end. Look,
he's even wearing his suit.
He's wearing a suit with his little
pocket square and now adorable.
He's in full panic mode, man. Full pain.
Yeah. So why don't you talk about how did,
uh, exactly you line this up. Okay.
So as it happened,
I subscribe to Dan Pena's Qla um,
like newsletter.
Okay.
So I get emails from his
center or whatever once a week.
And we had just done Joe Rogan's
podcast where we briefly mentioned Dan,
but we couldn't get into it because
Joe didn't want to, you know,
get into any kind of trouble
playing the guy's clips, right.
Head off and shit down their neck.
Yes.
So I get this random thing and it
just says, Hey, Dan Pena focus, uh,
featured on the Joe Rogan podcast with
Thompson [inaudible] and Christina
fidgets ski. And I, I look, I'm
like, oh my God, that's me. Like,
it was one of those spam emails. It
wasn't directed at me. They don't,
I've never made communication
with them before.
So I immediately just right back to
this like spammy email and I go, hey,
I'm Christina [inaudible] ski,
huge fan of Dan's.
We would love to have
him on your mom's house.
And not a few later I get a
direct message from Dan Pena.
Like, Hey, I heard you want
to get in touch with me.
And then Dan and I started
dming on Twitter. And we,
I got in touch with his assistant on
email and we arrange this interview.
But what a wonderful world we live in
that he just ran like he hears us on
Rogan.
No, just follow the
trajectory of the whole thing.
So like we were,
what was the story I told you?
I brought up something a few
weeks ago and you go, no,
it's not that weird because the internet
like the Internet, the Internet,
cause you brought it up. I bring it up.
Bikes kid or the bikes could write. Right.
And he ends up having his
ex girlfriend and for this,
what stood out to me was I
was just on Instagram. Yeah.
And happened to click a video with him
doing the like your foot while you're
fucking poor thing. Yeah. And that's how
you found him. That's how I found him.
That's how I found him.
Pena.
I sent that to blue band and I go put
this in the show breakdown next week.
Then like when I saw his name I go, I'm
going to look him up on Youtube. Yeah.
And that's when I found, remember I
go the first episode, I was like, oh,
I can't wait to play it for
you because I knew how much.
And that's the one where he was like a,
show me your friends, all your friends,
you know why you're fucking losers
because you have the fucking bumps,
you're hanging around.
So, and you were laughing.
Like those are things I just typed
in and I go, these are great clips.
I know this will be great for our show.
Then we talk about him on Rogan.
That reach is so massive that it
gets, uh, it gets back to him.
Ben,
and you see your name in a
piece of spam mail newsletter.
Yeah.
Cause he obviously he blasts out stuff.
Then we'll reach out and now he's on
our show. It's amazing. Yeah. It's just,
it isn't, it isn't. Right. Like I said,
like because the world now has shrank
so much because of the inner webs.
It's pretty, it's pretty Rad. And we
could Skype with shrunk and shrunk.
And is that the right way? I
don't know. Actually. I just
saw there, um, this is rad.
And we could Skype with this guy in
England who is eight hours I think. Fine,
right? Yeah. Yeah. So first
he tried to set up a Skype
session at 6:00 AM our time.
We we're like, um, no thanks.
Not Happening. Um, but yeah,
but first of all, sorry,
sorry. Okay, go ahead.
I just wanted to add an addendum to
the massage story and we didn't really
finish. Yeah, what happened,
right. So on the pre show, on,
on the pre show,
you may have skipped it,
but there's already the
origins of a story, right?
So we have a couple's massage,
which Tom's vehemently opposed to,
that's an exaggeration past.
And we do, I want to set it up.
You set it up and we tried it and
you fell asleep and started snoring,
which was so typical and I started kind
of giggling to myself and as you're
snowing I thought,
wouldn't it be funny when Tom Wakes up
to tell him that while he was asleep,
he farted so loudly that everybody
started laughing? [inaudible] exactly.
What causes that counterpart. So we
both were done with a mom. Sij and I,
I sit up and I go,
oh my God,
you farted so big and you're
like, what? I did? I'm like,
oh my God. It was so embarrassing. We
all started laughing. You didn't hear it,
you didn't hear it. Well then
I go like, no, I got you,
but you sold it so hard and you're
like, you fell asleep. And I go, yeah.
And you're like, I heard you
snoring. And I go, yeah. And you go,
you farted. And I laughed so hard
and then I was like, oh shit.
Did I really?
And,
and you actually convinced me only because
I remembered when it started. Yeah.
I go, oh, I got to Fart in
here. Oh, so the seeds were
planted and what I'm saying,
like I felt too far, but you know,
when you, you clamp down and you go,
I'm not going to part. Yeah. And then
sometimes it will just go away. Yeah.
But I was like, I must've fallen
asleep. Where does the Fargo, and then,
and I've asked therapists
before and they're like, oh,
farts happen all the time.
Yeah. And I go, what are you doing
there? That could be personal use to,
it just led the biscuits fly. Yeah.
They go, you know, it just happens.
Yeah. Because people relax. It's exactly
in that, in the scenario of describing,
there's someone's pushing on you and you
just relax. Rippling. Yeah. He grew up at,
but I can't, I got you. Good. And
I was getting ready to apologize.
I was getting ready to
mention it and not apologize,
but I was really getting ready to go.
Like, oh, I heard about what happened.
I couldn't let you do that. So then I
told you what happened. You got me good.
You really sold it. Good. Yeah.
I really didn't think. And then,
and then we fell off our primal wagons.
Oh my God. Pretty fucking hard. Well,
it wasn't Banis Murphy might
convince me to go for it. Go for it.
It's one night had
alcohol, fried food. Uh,
just that Mac and cheese.
We did it. We did desserts.
We back on the horse because I got
a beat Burt and the fat challenge.
That got a lot of work to do. Yeah.
Um, but it wasn't worth it. Honestly.
Like that's the funny thing.
You think you're,
you're being bad and having fun and
you're just like, I feel sick. Yeah.
It felt sick all night. I feel
terrible. And then there wasn't good.
But the good part about it was that I
had some really productive farts in the
hotel with you.
Yeah.
And that made the Ana this banished
merch for ne more special or you're very
gassy, more specialists. You are
a very gassy, I will say that.
And you did give me credit,
so I appreciate it. It was
really, really enticing.
Nothing makes me angrier or sad or
rather when I fart and then you don't
acknowledge it, you don't give me
credit for the fart. Yeah. I hate that.
It's like,
why do I live?
And yet a lot of thoughts to yourself
last night that you really enjoyed.
You were like right now,
like you're enjoying us.
Thinking about whether I enjoyed
them last night. You did.
There was a few thoughts you
had that you enjoyed a dinner.
Were you zoned out and you were like,
yeah.
And you let her know if
they know that enough.
The audience that we've talked
about this before with you,
that sometimes you think thought
like, great, now see kelp.
Caffeine. Okay, you, you think
thoughts? I've reset this thing.
I have no idea what to do.
I'm not kidding you.
This fucking thing I've downloaded it,
I've used is anti sleep system.
It's on.
All right, well I'm gonna fucking
know. Well, can I go ahead.
You have thoughts that you don't share
and you'll fully talk to yourself.
Like we'll be like this
and then you'll go,
that's a kind of exaggerated.
As soon as you go, well,
I have to do with sound so that the
audience just listening can hear it.
You'll be like,
okay,
yeah,
and you'll,
you'll laugh to yourself like a
crazy person and then I'll be like,
did you just have a thought that you
didn't share it? Sure. Yeah. I know.
I don't deny it. It's true, but why?
But share the fun thought because
I'm aligned with you want to,
I know if it's just keep telling you I
don't want to, but it's just you and me.
At dinner,
it's not fair.
Or today this morning we are having coffee
in the lobby and then you are on your,
I didn't have my phone and you were
reading fun tweets and you were like,
okay, good one. And I'm like,
can you share the fun thing but you
wouldn't share that one is a little
different than what you're comparing it
to though is that's reading something
and and enjoying it.
But when I have thoughts and you
go tell me what you just thought.
I don't want to,
I don't need to know all your thoughts,
but the ones that give
you laughter when you lab,
when you lol basically like how come you
have to share if you're going to lool
like no, then share the fun.
Never. No, it's never gonna change.
Well you know what,
what?
I just had a fun thought.
I know. How's it good one.
Yeah. All right. That's good. Dan Pena.
I am so excited. We talked
to Dan Penn. Yep. Blue Band.
Really turn these around quickly.
Thank you. Blue Band. And here you go.
Here's some of our conversation with Pena
will also upload it as its own longer
form. Just making you're recording.
I was like, are we not recording? No,
we are the red lights on.
Okay. I can't wait. I can't
wait. I can't wait. Here we go.
I just love him to
pieces. Uh, Dan, this is a
use is so exciting to us.
You have no idea. I mean,
I know you've seen the footage of us.
I'm talking about you were
huge fans and this is just,
uh, it's just a thrill for us. So, and you
look amazing today. Do you love, so dap,
you look like you're about one,
two 25
and you can kill a bear
without a fucking knife.
Yeah.
Well I can't actually,
no, no, no. That's what he said
in his video. His retort to Joe.
Yeah. He got really upset that
Joe called him old. He did.
He didn't learn it like that at all.
It's really interesting. He got real mad.
What, what is the back story
of you being the fifth,
the billion dollar man?
What? Well basically,
I'll just summarize that one cause
I don't think it's, you know,
I don't need to play the clip. Right.
Basically. So I was curious about it.
I know a lot of people were
wearing you the $50 billion man,
you're not worth $50 billion. The
number comes in, number comes from.
That's how much men teas have earned
collectively over his time as a business
and life coach for people.
Gotcha. So in other words,
if you add up all the value of,
of the people who have studied under
him what they've earned for over $50
billion, that's why he calls himself
that. So it's pretty, it's interesting.
And that's why he's called that.
I didn't tell people then.
It was harder for me.
To me, uh, the money I did because it was,
and I find it quite easy because one of
the questions I'm often asked me, dad,
why didn't you just continue to make
a lot of fucking money for yourself?
And I in quite frankly,
and I told the kids at Oxford University
and two months ago I found a pretty
fucking easy. So it wasn't
any fun anymore. Right.
But I thought if I could go cause
like you across the goal line. Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean that would be some fun.
But what I grossly underestimated
guys is how fucking hard it would be.
Get people who are low self esteem,
right. No balls. No. Right. Uh,
no, no. Self competence. It
had been raised by gifts.
Your parents across the door.
Loving part. No. Yes,
yes. Um, that was one of
the more fun parts of it.
Talk with them. That was great.
And um, I don't know if what the,
what you're going to play next,
but Dan and I had a discussion about how
you kind of do have to unlearn a lot of
the stuff that you were raised with.
There's a lot of stuff that your parents
had just may have passed down to you.
That's what therapist teach you to like,
yeah,
I'm learning the shit that doesn't
really work in the real world. Yeah.
And unlearning,
you know,
the essentially brainwashing
you're programming. Yeah.
Well there's a lot of dumb things.
Like in the case we,
you and I grew up in the Catholic faith.
Yeah.
There's a lot of stuff like turn the
other cheek. If somebody hits you,
give them the other cheek to hit
right. Not the, Jesus would give them,
offer them the other side to him as well.
Which to me is the dumbest thing to
tell somebody. No. If somebody hits you,
you fucking hit back.
You don't let somebody do that.
Are you fucking Steve Spurrier stay a
bed and the meek don't inherit the earth.
Uh,
they certainly don't know
if that's something you tell
them me so that they feel
good. Exactly right. There's a lot
of dumb shit. You grow up one anyway.
The only thing I do is if you want
to be mentored, me personally, uh,
you come to the castle and
you pay. But uh, 99.99,
9% of everybody that had benefit
of them cure late. I never met.
I never skyped up Facebook or tweet funds.
Wow.
That's a lot of fucking
fucked with us. Fuck, fuck to the DM.
Fucked and email fucked.
I'm dying to know. Dan,
why are people so fucking poor?
Good question, Jean. Thank you.
Wow.
Okay.
I want to try and do my best imitation
or Polish father telling his daughter
my dad retarded. You nailed it.
He did his research. He did.
He listened to us. Yeah, that
was great. That is great. Uh,
hang out with,
oh man,
hotels.
I didn't know that's what you did and how,
but somehow I bet I managed to stay.
I stay productive.
Then I stay productive. You
know, it fuels my business.
It feels my material.
But see that's a very,
it's a very smart approach
to a conversation.
I let the conversation began.
Lithic is knowing a little bit
about the people you're talking to.
After you introduced me
to the world of Dan Pena,
I immediately got on his website.
I read all the material I listened to,
you know a lot about, he's got a
podcast called ask the $50 billion man.
And it's hilarious because
he reads people. He's like,
check out my fucking site.
He'll be like, fucking shit. It's all on
the fucking website. Okay. Like he gets,
it gets upset, which is fine.
Agitated. They tell you stuff, he'll,
he'll tell he gives away stuff for
free. So it's great. Fucking hilarious.
He's such a wonderful treasure.
Dan Pena.
Well he was so, yeah, his dad was
a cop so he grew up really hard,
knocks plenty.
Uh,
I had a broken a kid.
Yeah.
I smashed the guy,
the glass window.
The eye glass dries.
Fortunately it was this site
and the coup de Gras, uh, was,
I dropped an aquarium from the second
floor on my teacher and if he hadn't moved
six inches, they woulda killed me.
But it only broke his collarbone. Oof.
Now my mother knew I was
just getting started.
I'm sure like grammar school, God only
knows what I do by the time I got out.
So she, she pressured my dad
and we moved to the battle.
No, you go. That's, that's my
story to that is your story.
I grew up in a hard streets and then
we went to the valley. Do you do it?
You also grew up partially in the
rough streets of Windsor, Ontario.
Yeah. Did you start to use more
as you when you moved to the UK?
Because I love it.
Okay.
Yeah,
he's too funny dude.
I don't even know what it's like now.
You can't even dress your boy up in
blue because that's considered a form of
child abuse cause he hasn't
decided his gender preference yet
and
it's,
I fear how he's going
to turn out under this
funny but ironic.
It's your daddy wanted to give him
right. The key though is that
we fired her, we fired her,
fired her immediately got the boot.
I know.
I think we almost did. I really did
almost blow a gasket on that. Yeah.
It was funny too by the way.
This is a total separate from this.
I just realized that I reacted the same
way now that I did in this video at the
same moment.
And I also saw you react the same way
like in the moment to like exactly the
same moment.
Wow.
That's cause they're genuine.
I know.
I always think about that when we play
that go. Great to see you make him laugh.
That was great. He was like
Ha. And you could tell.
Can you imagine if you worked
for him and you were like,
I'm going to do Reiki on your baby. But
he would do, he would fire me. He hit me.
He just said he would like to
make an exception to it. Lastly,
cause I know we don't have as much
time as always, you look incredible.
We wanted to know what's your
position on jeans? First of all,
the kids that probably gets a
write me an email me about that.
You know, they say big, big
airs or James at the bidding.
I guy that I don't know what happened
either seven or eight guys that I know.
I can say that I know and uh,
they don't wear jeans.
There you go.
Dan Pena does not wear jeans.
I don't do it for all
the success I've had. Uh,
the,
I have the least amount of followers,
right? Twitter kills me. It's weird.
You should have linkedin and
there's a reason. What's that?
Cause you're a fucking punk.
What his answer was,
most people call people a person
to cry if they're a obnoxious,
et cetera. Right? See when I call your
parents for your fucking cow. Okay. Okay.
All right. All right. Your
brain to do what's right.
Do you want to be liked by some other
cons? Yeah, right. Absolutely. Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, he owes and just so you guys, if
you do wanna know the answer, I think he,
he said the reason he's not as popular
in social media is because he calls
people constantly. I mean, he
basically, he calls you out,
I'm being a pussy. Right.
And, and fuck yourself. He doesn't tell
you it's okay to be weak and shitty. Yeah.
Which is really necessary,
by the way. I know it's been a week. Um,
we have a new president of
the United States coming to,
and this isn't a political
show by any means,
but I do feel like it's necessary
to say something. Uh, and it's,
it's a pretty simple and we'll,
and we'll move on.
Everybody gets so fired up and hot
headed and you came and talked to people.
Very personal thing. Politics
and religion, you know,
and people get too fired up and you
can't have, you can't have conversations.
What I was going to say though was
that, um, you know, uh, I don't,
I don't know if it's not really a mystery.
I didn't, I was not a fan, not a fan of,
of Trump.
Okay.
Never didn't ever wanted him to be
president and a never thought it'd be
possible. But I will say that
I think it's important, um,
to now that he's won, you know,
the, uh, the rig system, uh,
came together, kind of worked
in his favor. He won, you know,
I feel like you have to give your,
for the benefit of your country,
give them a shot. And, um, just
I, you know, like I'm sending,
you can be disappointed, but you got to
give him a shot and see what happens. So,
yeah, I mean, I agree. It's
not, it's not the end. It's
not the end of the world yet.
Let's see.
Let's not panic.
And everybody's in their initial
reaction is some of us are horror panic.
A lot of people are really depressed
and anxious, but let's, so, let's see.
Absolutely.
So, um, we'll move. I do have, I
did think I'll give him credit.
I thought he gave a very
nice, uh, victory speech, uh,
when he came out. I have a small clip
from that and then we'll move on. This,
this is him, uh, moments, you know,
after accepting that he is the
president elect of the United States
Chile
sheet.
I know she's bad,
but audit starving dog shit and the dust
storms have you run it out of prince
frozen burrito covers.
Got a solution.
That's what you said last time.
Did I got a solution here?
There you go. So that was um, a
beautiful moment from that speech and um,
let's hope that America
America is great again.
That sounded like we're,
we've returned to greatness or we're
all great. Thank you. We're back. Um,
when do you,
how long before he does start shooting
rifles in the air during speeches you
think could, I don't know, it could be the
most entertaining for years ever, right?
We're about to embark on, it's
definitely going to be great for comedy.
I think it's going to be great for a
Saturday night live the great for the arts
in general. Yeah. I think we're going to
have another, a renascence if you will,
with the artists I do freaking out.
Cause God knows the comedy world is
losing their mind right now. Yeah,
they're fired up.
Um,
so do you remember a while back?
Jeans. We had a, I love you.
You love me. Can I just say that? I
love you. Thank you. I do. I love you.
I think you're a wonderful man.
I'm glad we've been married so long.
Let's just hit you right now.
It just hit me because look,
if the world is going to fall to
pieces because of President Camacho,
then I just want you to know I
love you and we've got a compound,
um,
built underground.
We can survive the nuclear holocaust
and we can love each other. Oh yeah.
There's no problems. And our two dogs
were all should be fine. Our bunker is,
um, we got our water supply, we got
our backup generator. Um, when the, um,
the nuclear bombs hit, it'll,
it'll be fine. Be Great.
You guys have our podcast to listen to.
I love you too. Jeans. I love you
too. Yeah. Um, the end of the world.
So here's what I wanted it to play.
So do you remember a while
ago we played this, um,
this British hooligan fan who
was like saying blood and Fam?
Yeah, that's a good
one. He's back. Oh good.
There's an interesting I think
note about this guy. Okay. Okay.
Uh, fam blood fam fam. Yes.
That one stuck to me for
a while. This time. Uh,
we were talking to after he
lost lost, uh, Tottenham,
which used to be a shitty team,
but is now much better.
Tottenham I think I said it
is tall, tall, tall. Although,
um,
the author is it top told him.
How do you spells t o
t t t t n h. A. M. Huh.
Tall,
Tall Gloucester.
This guy. Anyways, he, he,
he has a pretty great accent,
but he also has the slang
that you don't get to hear.
I mean I've, I mentioned fam, I've heard,
but I've never heard it like you used
a hundred times and write two minutes
blood.
I don't hear a lot about it
before, but isn't there like an old
jive Chang lose blood? I was like,
oh seven and he's black and
the name. Okay, well, okay,
he's a black man with your medicines back.
Why was a bit disappointed in the end
from awesome Kay was it was just dead
money. It was dead, right? They was dead.
There was no passion. There was no Dody.
Masha and passion was cooking in blood.
This is a north London
Darby family and us.
That was the biggest game
of the season so far. Blog.
I look where they go and do your blood.
Look when they go and do even up blood,
I'm a bigger, what we found are you
missing them? Opportunities. Blood.
You free one on one blood.
You aren't so much time like to pick your
corner blood and you hit Australia to
keep her blood. Even Mustafi
he was getting Rick blood,
you know, I love my staff.
He blood,
this guy's out of blah, blah, blah.
First there was no shape.
Bloody Mama all over the Gulf farm.
There was nothing there. Blood Bellarine
but Rick, you understand what gay replied
[inaudible] or didn't do his thing.
Alexis was was was writing man down,
but there was nothing really
to the game blood. It was dead.
Talk like this. Yeah, really
all the time. I don't know.
I'd never heard blood.
I've heard that this might be a clip
here from this guy for the master of
accidents. So just let me, let me just,
sorry, master. Put your headphones on.
Get My, all right. And let's see.
I don't give a shit about it
and he cut blood. Let me rule.
Obviously we wouldn't it. Yeah. Cool.
But I don't really care for that.
I handled my idol, not blood. I
don't look at it. You to think. Oh,
we'll we playing talking him into Leacock.
I think when we played them in
the lead blood, come on blood,
which we will be games. A tough
game. Star becomes a tight game.
Why do they always turn up and we don't
recently blood. Why is that funny?
Why do you play it not for this fucking
game. Blood. Even the fans blood.
I'm a big fan. I'm a big supporter.
I, but today was shit. I'm walking up.
It ain't no fucking songs. There's
no bank that was, she was dead
good. That wasn't hard to,
I understood all that. Yeah.
I feel like mad about the team.
Yes. They said that this clip here,
the interviewer tries to suggest that
the team that they lost who was good and
that, oh, maybe upsets this guy. Okay.
We got to get him a lot of credit
and beat them. We have to give them
listen whether we like them or not,
we have to give them respect
that they are not a shit team.
They are a couple of older, second
day our goods team. There's,
it's a simple as that.
We don't want to have me
sports do sports or like politics too.
It's so much like that seems bullshit man.
And they get so,
so fired up. I know. It is. Here's the
blood family. Super Cool. Excellent.
It was just dead man,
Blah Blah Blah Blah and blah blah blah
to blah blah blah blah and blah blah blah
blah blah blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
So many, it's so many. Yeah.
It's, it's such a weird drop.
I know. And I always love is when, um,
somebody like that is being interviewed
and he has to really treat that person
like somebody of intelligence that has,
I think he that I know.
I know what you're saying
in a general sense. I think
he knows who that guy is. A,
he's at home. Yeah. He knows that
this guy was a good interview.
Good in the sense that he's entertaining,
you know? Yeah. And he has to be like,
how do you feel? Yeah. Like
blood for blood, blood time, Bam,
Bam, Bam. Black. That black fab time.
Nothing like the soccer hooligans.
They really love their side.
Do speaking of accents.
Yeah.
And the UK,
we have a full tour of UK accents.
Right. Oh, I love it. Let's do it.
Yeah. This is something as a master,
right. People have asked me, you know,
can you do this one came through that one.
The answer is always yes.
But now to educate us further.
We're going to take this tour of an,
and I lived in England
for a year in the 90s.
So I feel like I can contribute to this
discussion. I mean I'm, I'm no master.
Yeah, and right. Yeah. Am I
in a Prentice? Oh, for sure.
Yeah,
of course.
Perceived pronunciation
is the great communicator.
As soon as you deviate from that and
you're going to London speech for example,
then you lose a little
bit of the communication.
Courtney is based on East Anglian sofic.
Norfolk came richer.
This is often by actors confused with
the West country where the hour has come
in and then you get Dorset and
Somerset get into Cornwall.
Devon slightly definitely goes
in the nose a bit more like that.
Then you go up north to Yakutia.
It's nice if you get the word that Scott,
one of the predominant.
That sounds very Downton Abbey,
Downton Abbey. Where was down? Well,
the way he said I'm a good Yorkshire Lass.
Yeah.
You said Yorkshire Shoah.
They, the aristocracy.
The aristocracy lived.
I just,
they would always take the
train into London to write.
They were country people Downton,
so maybe that is your,
I do know that the,
the royal to the ton to talk.
This is true with the chin out and a
bit of a more nasal [inaudible] and then
you know, again the cognate people,
they get it. It's like Boston Bro. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's nice if you get a word that's got
one of the predominant sounds in it like
yard, then you cross the
[inaudible] into action. Which Mall?
That sounds like the way
he just said that. Yeah.
That your sounds like the um,
the farmers on Downton Abbey.
Yeah.
The people that work at the actual,
so it didn't sound like the down the
farmers. Yeah. Yeah. The people, the,
the actual working class sounds like the
downstairs people, if you will. Yeah,
but that's exactly how they would
say things. You know, I wonder,
I wonder where land kiss
shy or directionally or
not. Does that take place?
We can look it up on this thing called
the inner webs to the Google machine.
Um,
where does Downton Abbey take place?
Where,
where did the porno take place? Remember
the season finale was so crazy. I mean,
the series finale,
when they all had sex with each
other and stairs and downstairs,
it's in Hampshire.
Help share about five
miles south of Newbury,
Berkshire back chart. That doesn't
really help me. And they're like,
where the fuck is that now are you,
are you googling where the actual
building Downton Abbey. Yeah. Um,
she see where the show takes
place. It can be, let's see.
God Damn [inaudible]
come a hell lot of comm.
And then Birmingham, Bam,
Bam. Okay. Let's see.
Where does Downton Abbey, I love it
when our Internet's never work. We've,
we've installed about four
different lines in this house.
It's in the Fictional Yorkshire
County. I just read that. Yeah.
Fuck your mother for Yorkshire Country
Estate. Okay, so it's Yorkshire.
So that's exactly where in Yorkshire?
Yeah, North Yorkshire. Right there.
You'll see how the master picked it
up though. So good. You did? Yeah.
How did I get Yorkshire Lad
word that Scott, one of the predominant
sounds in it, like yard shear.
Then you've crossed the pen eyes into
lanky share where it gets much more
flexible and fluid in the mouth
live. The tool is there to, you know,
it's scouse to mixture
of all kinds of sounds.
One of those keys, Northern Irish
with the raising and fluxions,
but you don't get the rising inflection
stone on Joplin where it has that poetic
quality,
which is sometimes sort of as being
not different from Highland speech,
which is uh, uh, also, uh,
quite poetic and almost Scandinavian.
And then you come down to Glasgow and
into the lowlands of school and where are
you get clause stalks
and things like that.
And then you come down the west coast
and you're in wheels north Wales where
it's breathy like that and
down into South Wales. Well,
you've got too much heavier and Welsh
people sometimes even sound a bit drunk.
Yeah. This guy is so good. So
good. Did I feel like he could be,
he could sign up for my,
my master's program where he comes
and stays in the house castle and uh,
we just practice accents. Yeah. You know,
you should invite him to your layer.
Boy, he's got to pay. But I'm saying
he's really, he's getting ready.
I feel like to take the course. Can I tell
you the Welsh accent is, in my opinion,
the hardest to understand of these people.
That shit is bananas hard.
And then you have a few
pints of beer and you,
you can understand what the fuck
these people are saying to you. Yeah.
And by the way, uh, trainspotting
two is coming out. Yeah.
We talk about some accents.
I'm super stoked. There's
whole chunks of that movie.
I don't understand a fucking word.
Francis Begbie says, oh no film. And I'm,
I'm Gareth Jamison.
I'm an actor and a voice coach from
www.londonvoicelessons.com. Cool.
Harrison, do you, um, do you, can
you believe it 20 years later though?
It's so fun. It went by
so fast. Yeah. I mean,
I was in college when that movie came
out and I was like my favorite movie
episodes. You remember like beat the
first time or you're like, wait, what?
What'd he just say?
Beats like beats in the movie moment.
Frances Frances Beg me that, that the
sociopathic guy that throws the beer.
I don't want to, I didn't understand
most of what he says in that film.
There's an entire scene where he's talking
to like he's telling a story to spud
or something and understand
a fucking word. I know,
I know was a bit out of that bed and he
throws the pint of beer and someone's
screens and the only real lunatics and
then whatever. It's such, I can't wait.
Yeah.
Tips for working on
your voice and I'll the,
I like those. Really cool. Real cool.
The key to any accent. Okay. Isolate the
sounds that are specific to that accent.
So in the Welsh shacks,
and quite often you'll hear people saying
that it's a very sing songs sort of
sounding accent.
The reason for this is that in Welsh acts
and what tends to happen is that vowel
sounds are stretch out and stressed and
there's a huge glide from high pitch to
low pitch.
The accident I'm talking about is the
South Wales Act and there's actually quite
a huge difference between south and north.
We're focused on the south Wales.
So listen to this sentence,
John,
what do you do when John,
what do you do when no discharge?
You do and that's good.
Do it again. A huge John,
what do you do and can I get John,
what do you do?
And John,
what do you do when
John,
what are you doing
there?
Notice that huge glide on John.
She's much more common in males than it
is in other parts of being of the United
Kingdom,
but it's not exclusive to Wales.
Keon what do you do when John?
Notice that at the end as well to
run than it sound in doing too.
When we we're getting pit
and when it hit and pick,
it becomes more like an air,
so that's and bet they have a
better that please. Is He doing
American accent? That'd be great if
this guy did American of this guy.
He does how to do a Scott. He
does American Dad, let's hear it.
He's all California.
Browse talk like this bro.
He's like Sally girl.
Once you want to do is sound old.
Fucking stupid like this. Hey, hey man.
Hey Man.
Drove your eye color that 80 Jamison.
I'm an actor and the volume,
you want to go to Mcdonald's and you might
want to do an American accent because
you're in a play or a film or maybe you
want to impress your friends want to be
done. Maybe you want to try and fit in
better in the USA. Whatever the reason,
weird thing to do to try to
fit in better on the US side.
Adapt a an accident on a vacation.
Playing with accidents is a great way
to stretch your voice and exercise your
speech.
Oh,
now the key to doing any accent is to
isolate the specific sounds that occur in
that accent.
But today I can only give you a brief
overview of some of these sounds.
Of course, the USA is huge and
there are many different accents,
so we're going to go for one that's called
general American and start again with
the sound Americans use for the letter
arc. Okay. Now listen to this sentence.
Are there more birds?
Totally. Are there more birds
there? More birds? Are there more birds?
Are there more birds?
He's really,
like I said it more American by listening
to him. Yeah. Are there more birds?
Clear? He cleaned it up for
you and did he really did
are now listen to this sentence.
It's right. Are there more birds?
Are there more birds? Are there
more burden? Can you adjust it?
Every time there's a letter
R it's pronounced and that's
a good general rule for
American. Every letter are in the word
gets pronounced. Are there more birds?
Also? It's a very dark sound.
Might help you to think about this.
A sound coming from right at the back of
the throat that here are there more for
terrible there nick.
The only sound terrible compared
to the beautiful UK. It sounds.
Do we sound fucking retarded? Look, I
have to work on what I've been working on.
You can be here for it,
but
that's your front line. Shanti. Oh.
Shantay that's be asked to be on.
That's terrible. Do that
again. Be on Sir. No, no.
Do you need to practice
beyond sir? Beyonce? Beyonce.
Pardot please.
Macy BUCO MERCI book. I'm
so much better. No, no,
no, I did really well. So you're learning
French now and the airplanes? Yeah,
I do it to occupy my time. When do you
have time in between the Strip clubs?
I don't, well, what happens is I'll go
into a strip club with headphones on
and you'll then sometimes they'll go like,
yeah, man, don't want to take those out.
And I'll be like, I'm working on
my friend. I'll say, no, I don't
see beaucoup. MERCI.
MERCI beaucoup. Beyonce.
Here's what can I tell you why I did this?
So people know.
So I finished Spanish in
high school as a sophomore.
I took the AP. Well, yeah,
there's a little advantage.
I had a little advantage,
right? And I passed. I had to like A's
or with everything. So they go, yeah,
you just take a second language.
So what I did was I signed up for French
and I got a d and I was always really
disappointed in it. Then
a few years later, I,
I forget online or something,
I found a French tutor and I go,
I'm going to try to do this again.
And I met with her a couple times.
She gave me tapes.
This was when there was cassette tapes.
Listen to these tapes of practice.
I gave up in, I don't know,
a week or two. Oh, I bet.
Then I signed up for this online course
about somewhere between 15 and 18 months
ago and I did it for a
couple days and then I,
the reason I never mentioned it was
I was like, cause you, I quit again.
And the reason I mentioned to you at
this time is that I've gone further get
free. So you don't, when you're like,
it's like a diet where you're like,
I'm not going to say anything until
I know I'm doing it. So far you,
I'm in the beginner stages, but I've
done four or five beginner things.
It's hard when you're not immersed,
I think in the language.
You're not forced to show up
to a class or live, you know,
live in France and France land. Yeah.
For Awhile. But uh, that's good.
Good for you.
Yeah.
I studied German in college and I almost
failed by the time I got to German
three almost failed out.
I think I got like a d,
I think I'm going to try to do a
few of these, you know, with the,
with the languages that
come more naturally,
you can incorporate it and you're
deejaying. He can yell out.
You can be like that European Dj, dad
mouth, you know, there's, there's that,
there's also, you gave me this great
idea to try to be a retarded comedian.
And I was thinking, what if I did
that? But in multiple languages, I,
that's a duck.
They're not going to hold me to this
same vocabulary that enable minded person
would have. Right? So what if I did?
I'm retarded, but I do this in French,
Spanish,
Portuguese and Italian.
Then you can appeal to all
retarded people in all cultures.
It's such a beautiful idea on your part.
And I saw one of their credit
you with that. Thank you.
It's the retarded people of the world.
It's a global act.
Now you can go ahead and your agent
can thank me for that idea. Well,
you know, you can give him
a call. Tell him I'll, I'll,
I mean I'll definitely give you
credit. Um, also don't forget,
um, by the way, today I was,
we share a booking agent and
we were talking about for
Eit said Fort Lauderdale.
He corrected me and said, Oh,
you mean fart louder now. Wow.
And I go, and he just turned your
commission on the was a good one.
Are you going to go to Fort
Lauderdale? We'll see. We'll see.
We'll see if there was to work out the
deal, Tom. Okay. It's all about the deal.
Um, don't forget. Uh,
I'm standing there and I smell what
smells like somebody just dumped an entire
container of coffee in the shower like
somebody took, I don't know what that is.
When the RAF and just,
you drink water today, dad. First of all,
always been a big water drinker.
He is like Brown. We should measure
who drink some more water a day.
Why don't we do a water challenge?
I'm fucking you right now, bro. Okay,
let's do this.
It's so ridiculous.
Accurate,
so much water or more
songs during the show.
So many great,
but this one is of course about the water.
She knows her shit about me being the
water flowing and they can see the
manipulation.
He could never drink as much water.
There's online support with Tom
is the best done a big fat liar.
Here's the evidence. Remember? Wow.
It's so great.
So again,
that's the Watergate
Emami Distrac or gain.
God,
that felt good too.
We had that Teresa mom let this
morning and I really liked it.
I forgot how much I enjoyed Theresa.
Actually. You got me to enjoy soyrizo.
Yeah, that's a good alternative to
the nastiness of, of real Theresa. Um,
so then we were sent a,
a comment,
it's on one of our youtube videos.
Youtube comments are that
usually most flattering.
That's where people really let you know
how much they like this is actually has
made me, this made me laugh so hard.
This is from a Dj dad mouth video. Okay.
So there's two Trone wrote
this Nigga gay as shit.
He could say he's non numeric or whatever,
but if you suck in Dick,
you gay as fuck the fuck kind of a
name is DJ dad now DJ dad mouth Bro.
The fuck. Also. He's mad corny,
but really thinks he's really fly with
that dead squirrel around his rusty ass.
Nick.
This is what hip hop has turned into.
We've let too many white people in and
now they've brought that weird shit.
There you go. That's the best thing
that I've read all day. Donald Trump,
the hip hop world.
You've ruined it.
The fact that this dude thinks that
this is a real Dj. It's really,
really fantastic. That's
it. Yeah. It's just, it's
like he can't pick up on the irony of
bad jewelry or for all the crazy stuff
you're saying. Or the fact that you're a
standup comic who was really well known.
Well, I just think it's great that
he's like, just is ruin in hip hop
Tony Mann and agree with them though.
I think Dj dad mouth is ruining hip hop.
Here's an email that came in.
I've been listening to the classic
jeans and much to my dismay I found out
during a, would you rather it turns out,
mommy, Tina is the water champ. The,
would you rather consistent of eating a
week's worth of your bathroom trash? Um,
or being or only being able to bathe
once a month and then having a drink.
The bath water. Mommy, Tommy,
much like a true Barry chose to eat the
trash you floss and all but mommy, Tommy,
mommy, Tina, like the true water champ.
She is took drinking the dirty ass
bath water like a true champion.
Love you all. Please come back to
go bananas and do a live podcasts.
Keeping them high and tight.
My big words Dan.
Thank you Dan.
Sounds like you are not smart.
So let's move it along.
Damn.
Thank you for being a real champion fan.
Thank you. Jeans. Do you remember this?
This is in our breakdown. Oh
my God. Christina p fan site.
That's like one of the
first websites ever made.
It's got that real html kind of build
this website someone made back in my road
rules. It's 20 years old and they
still put, they keep it up. Sweet.
Uh, this is the only the one and
only true dedicated Christina piece.
I can Christina piece,
thankful for being rescued.
This nice person put together this site.
They took photographs of the television.
That's how old it says, and
they, uh, they put it up.
Thank you for bringing
this to my attention again,
after joining us in the
breakdown. I didn't know I
couldn't do that. Now you can.
It's silly. It's, it's really sweet
at that person kept it up this long.
I'm really,
it's an angel fire website to hard core,
hard fucking card fucking core.
That was a very fat are flattering and
there's a guest book there where people
would write things is before comments.
Yeah.
Really great old school guys.
You know what's really crazy
is that there's generations,
there's like people that were children
watching me on road rules now who they
came out to my shows and I'll be like,
I've been watching you since I was a kid.
Like, oh no. I don't know if I
like that. I mean I'm thankful,
but we're thankful that you did it.
No,
I'm thankful that they've
followed me for so many years,
but it makes me feel really old.
How fucking old am I?
I'm only 40 how are you a child? When
you started watching me, I'll know
somebody wrote about Lion Tina.
He said, how long do we have?
Do we give it until Tina says she saw
Cuba Gooding jr break up a fight in New
York City. Chris, I saw that.
That's so funny. That is funny.
I saw it in San Francisco.
So fucking fun.
It's funny for you time waiting on
the Tom versus burr psycho debate.
He says, Tom is hundred 50% more
psycho than bill. Thank you.
First, let's be clear. Tom Is definitely
the water champ and stuff like that,
but laughing your buns off to a guy's
reaction to getting his legs crushed by a
car is Ted Bundy level craziness.
So Christina,
I'm with you on this phone.
Tom Has that blood loss boiling up inside
and needs to go hunting with powerful
Joe Rogan to release all that before the
body starts piling up bigger than the
poop
pile. Thanks for being awesome and
helping me when I'm feeling bad.
You guys are a fun couple of peace
and love. Daniel Daniel, finally.
Thank you. I appreciate that.
You're absolutely right.
My husband is a murderous lunatic
who needs to get that side out
just for a little, uh,
balance here. Another email.
I've listened to burrs
podcasts for a while.
It's actually how I got
turned onto your mom's house.
It takes about five minutes of
listening to that show to realize what a
psychopath bill really is.
Tom is not even close to that level.
J fizzle. Jay, you seem like a
really, really sharp guy and uh,
I'm 100% in agreement with you.
He is out of his fucking mind.
So, um, somebody wrote, uh,
what did they say here?
Couldn't help but notice
the Mousse spotting noise
that hunter made and a great
idea.
Could this sound be in the rotation of
chips in a bowl and the cat cat eating
which sound
sorry. When he goes to us and I think
right before the glass, you know?
Yeah. Like he's, he's like, Ooh, Ooh, Ooh.
Can we get so excited? What was the
other one we talked about this morning?
The guy was super stoked. Oh, ego's
so big bite. Oh really big, bad.
Not a bad buy. Got a bad boy. You
got a bad back about. Bye Bye.
Bye. [inaudible]. Just
glad that must've been.
It was amazing.
Just because it's such a dad boner,
she's going to go down right there.
No way
ever seen him lose come down.
I quick. Oh No. Oh my God.
I was raised.
That is awesome.
Oh my God. So much joy. I just love
that guy's an enthusiasm. Yeah.
Uh,
I think this is right.
Yeah,
good suggestion.
I love it.
Great idea. It just
glass, which is classic.
Just glassing look,
go to bad boy.
I go to bed slipping along here,
just glass and
we're just glassing let's glass
glass, glass, glass. I'm like,
yeah,
that's amazing.
What should I call it? Sound
sure. Whatever. Yo you remember,
cause let's hear his name.
God, the Dad and dad.
Moose. Dad Moves, Dad Boner, boner Moose.
Good for him with a life
just and just glass. Glass,
glass, just class. Let's
just keep going. So glass,
glass,
glass or glass.
And I'm like, holy smokes. I got a moose.
We going. I'm like, Oh man, it's a ball.
It's a ball. I'm like, no,
it's a cow. A cow. Right there.
That is just a really good idea.
Yeah, it's fine. We sent that in.
I got to give him credit. Good
suggestion bro. Nice. Nice set man. Um,
let's see. The idea
came from mommy. Austin.
Thank you mommy. Austin.
Yeah. Really good man. Oh,
Mommy's is a watch. Patrion number
seven. It looks to me like mommy.
Tina is sabotaging Tommy's hydration.
She sits there with an open lacroix,
the choir next to her,
yet she was drinking Tom's Perrier,
I call fuckery. If you see something,
say something Sean.
Well that,
that brings to our attention that Patriot
has been off the fucking chain lately
and it's been really fun.
It really has been. So, um,
first of all,
thank you Shawn.
And she does pull a lot of bull show
said when it comes to hydration,
whenever dudes, um, I have my
things I can flash is not cool.
She doesn't share and she's
selfish and that's just, you know,
that's just kind of what I have
to deal with. So there you go.
Happy anniversary, Tom. Happy
Anniversary. Now, you know,
look,
I gave you the guys,
sometimes you give me the eye
roll, which we learned. Oh,
contempt is content and we saw
a documentary or a therapist,
a marriage therapist said if,
if that's a sign of contempt,
if you see that and contented,
that song of bad content means
you're going to divorce. I said,
that's a huge indicator of divorce.
It's contempt. Yeah. And you went
and sometimes you give me a triple I roll.
I don't give you triple,
quadruple.
You do eye rolls on it like you
don't do I rolls. Yeah. Oh my God.
You have so much contact
or I wrote so much. Really?
Yeah. I had this clip from your, um,
show that you were at last week. Okay.
I can videos post videos on Facebook,
but this is for you because the last time,
but the video was posted. You was
meant open up my place. No such thing.
I'll wait if you twice
and I was Eric in today.
Were you asked to meet me and were
arguing? I do show my niche. You and I,
lesbian crew is not here.
No one's here.
There you go. Okay. I love that
it's actually that the gypsy, um,
calling out videos for fights has
expanded to women. I didn't really,
that's what this was. I didn't know
that there is a bunch of Gypsies,
which you openly are racist against.
Oh,
that Roma Keith [inaudible]. Yeah. Yeah.
Everybody hates the Gypsies.
We know that.
And so that's what she's
squatters. They're squatters. Yeah.
They are squatting or Gypsies.
I didn't know that's what she's calling
out the bitch for not being there again.
She's like a bitch. Just like
the dude's dude. You know,
the dudes are like, bye. Oh,
phobia. But now there's a woman. The
woman makes it way more exciting.
Why more a woman fighting is
more excited only in that you go,
this is such a departure from
the norm. Yes, of course.
It's bizarre when a woman
fights physically. Uh,
but why works or that's from the Gypsy
show. That is right. I think she just,
she's got way worse. Uh, so
very interesting. So this is a,
an English gypsy. It's, it looks,
yeah.
Yeah. They're kind of, they're good,
but her outfits good. I like her.
I think she's dressed in a little
too nicely for a, for a fight.
I wouldn't wear white to a fight.
It's going to get red. Yeah.
Whether you win or lose. And it's
also, it's kind of tracksuit, isn't it?
This is zip up her cruise.
All right though, man. There.
Okay. Good looking moms.
Yeah. I don't know about that.
Women fighting is bizarro.
I guess we're not, I'm not
even like everyone else. Yeah.
When it was really slow in the MMA
and Mama, it was my low ascension
and then they got a superstar to her,
which she helped the business of female
fighting really grow, you know? Yes.
But I remember when it first
started, people were like, no,
I don't want to fucking see
the appointment fight now.
Now it's become a thing where people are
just as excited to see people want to
see stars. They want to see high level.
If you can get some higher level fighters,
female tennis players on the streets.
When two women fight, it's like,
yeah, but can I tell? Yes.
Having grown up here, um,
I actually saw more girl fights and I did.
Dude fights between gang
bangers and public school.
Like the Cholos would get real like Cholos
get 100 and fucking and fighting each
other way. Way More. Wymore all you had
to dudes I saw. Oh yeah the girls. Yeah.
Oh Yay. Yay. Yay. Yay. She's going to
get why works or why? Why bars her?
Cause she's calling them out just like
the dude's do on this. Oh here's the pub.
I'm going to fucking
fuck. Fuck you up. Yeah.
Oh
cause she was there last night
cause she just low lights and you can't
get shit cause you have rich millionaire
mum. Dad Won't give you
bread. As a matter of fact,
he makes you get peaks
or on Christmas Day.
Yeah.
First of all,
this first bitch that came up a lot.
She was intense.
Gypsy look though, that's how they
rock it. You know the hair. Yeah.
I just thought that other lady was
like a soccer mom but she's a real,
she's a real ne Romany shale.
I'm a Romney jail.
She's got to yeah, totally perfect smile.
Perfect. Perfect smiles in right there.
See She, she put it in right.
But I'm making the video.
How long [inaudible]
miles out and put them up.
There we go.
There you go. Perfect smile. Um Man,
that first ladies a savage.
Oh my God
Sean. I met Joe live out cause
she was there last night.
One. Yeah my cousin.
Yeah cause you were there
last night so she's clear.
Worry took our money out.
Buy a place cause she's just slow lives
and you can't get shit cause you have
rich millionaire. God won't give
you bread. As a matter of fact,
he makes you geek pizza on Christmas Day.
Her voice is like pills,
smoke, smoke, smoke, smoke,
those that real ramen.
Acio lifestyle. Yeah.
A lot of hard booze and hard
liberal party all fucking day. Yeah,
I do a fuck about shit. Shit. Shit. Sorry.
Jeez man.
These broads got a lot of time.
Who's got that kind of time to
call out fights with people?
I mean you really got to
have no life and Jesus,
you know what I was going to fuck her
is that we're doing right now furniture
shopping. You really are, is it
is right. It stressing me out.
Well, it's just one of
those things where you don't
think about it, that you're, when you
move, sometimes you go like, oh yeah,
if I don't get something this room,
we'll just stay on.
I know. And you know what, we, we really
don't have a lot of furniture. Oh yeah.
We've lived on anything
really small apartments. Yeah.
So when you move into a house,
you're like, oh, there's
nothing for this house. No.
And we also buy like frat boy
furniture. We have, um, electric.
Uh, what are those called
to the recliner chairs.
Like here's how bad we were
with the folders. Crusher
told us that it was a
frat boy chair. Well, you have Burt
going like, Hey, uh, some of your chair.
Yeah. Frat. That's,
you know, you're, well,
the problem with you and I is that
we like comfort over fashion. I know.
Pricers fat. I know. So, you know,
I can't fucking say I can't buy something
that I can't use. It makes me crazy.
It's true. It's such a bummer.
Yeah, it is. It's such a bummer.
I like the perfect smile. I just want
it to be set up. I know jeans, it's all,
you know. I know you get, you want
everything to be done and I know that,
but it takes a little time. I got to
call this fucking asshole now too.
I just remind you, you fucking asshole.
The baby's safety gate people. I know.
It's a process and it fucking
sucks. Dude is moving. Listen,
there is no hell worse than
moving point blank period.
Point blank period is get your life and
you suck it up and it just sucks for
like a month, dude. I'm saying. You know
what I'm saying? No, what you're saying.
I know what you mean and I know what
you're talking about. I know it.
Yeah. Anything else? Jeans.
That's it. I love you. I,
I'm happy band a SMURF. Ferny.
Thank you for listening to our show.
Come see us. Do stand up live. Yeah.
Amazon banner and use ours to do
your shopping this holiday season.
Water champ shirt,
water champ shirts.
Go get one of those for
Christmas for your loved ones.
Here is a closing song.
It's a six buckets.
Okay, nice. All right. See you
next week. Bye guys. I, mommies
[inaudible]
Stephanie, they're going to get
it. They're going to get it.
Get up and watch it.
Watch it.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
All right.
Money.
I'm the executive director.
All right.